if you want to have more invention
you need to do more experiments per week
per month per year per decade it's that
simple
getting people to to believe in what
you're doing
and in in you is is important i remember
going on cnbc the business channel
and then the guy going boy don't you
feel stupid that yahoo stock has kept on
going up and you had this hedge
and i'm like yeah i feel so stupid
riding around my g5 that i bought online
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn the seven best lessons
from elon musk
bill gates and other billionaire
entrepreneurs
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one experiment with jeff bezos
to be innovative you have to experiment
if you want to have more invention
you need to do more experiments per week
per month per year per decade it's that
simple
you cannot invent without experimenting
and here's the other thing about
experiments
lots of them fail if you know it's going
to work in advance
it is not an experiment
and what happens in big organizations
that amazon's a big organization now too
the air force is a big organization
is that we start to confuse
experimentation
with operational excellence so
we you know operational excellence is
one of our four key principles
at amazon we're building
a fulfillment center we've built over
150 large fulfillment centers around the
world now
we know how to do that that is not an
experiment
if we build the 151st fulfillment center
and screw it up that's just
a failure that's not the kind of failure
we're seeking
we want failures where we're trying to
do something new untested never proven
that's a real experiment and they come
in all scale sizes
lesson number two be persuasive with
elon musk
if you think about a company a company
is is a group of people that are
organized to create a product or service
that's a sort of company is so in order
to
create such a thing you have to convince
others to
join you in in your effort um
and and and so they have to be convinced
that
that that it's a sensible thing that uh
it's like that there's at least some
some good some reasonable chance of
success uh and if there is success that
the reward will be commensurate with the
effort involved
um and uh
you know so i think that's getting
people to to
believe in what you're doing uh and in
in you is is important
um so in in the beginning
there will be there will be a few people
who
who believe in you or what you're doing
and but then over time as you make
progress
the evidence will build and and more
people will believe in what you're doing
so um i think it's a good idea when
creating a company to
um to create it to have a demonstration
or you know
if it's a product to have like a a good
mock-up or
even if software to have good demo wear
or to be able to sketch something so
people can really envision what it's
about
um like that that's a try to get to that
point as soon as possible and then
iterate to make it as as real as
possible as fast as possible
lesson number three love what you do
with bill gates
today the greatest pleasure of your life
is when you're doing what
is it other than being interviewed by me
or something like that what are the
great
greatest pleasure of your life uh you
know
time with kids time with scientists
uh time when i'm reading and things are
making sense
you know going out and seeing the impact
of the foundation's work
uh meeting with scientists who think we
can
make breakthroughs to help solve climate
uh you know these are super interesting
problems
and you know having a broad set of
system thinking applied to these
problems
is going to be necessary uh to
orchestrate the resources and policies
behind them so
you know i love i love my work also if
you want to have more self belief and
more self confidence i have designed a
free training program just for you
or every day for the next 254 days i'll
send you
an email with an unlisted video to help
you boost your confidence
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
and so i want you to build the habit of
self-belief and self-confidence
it's 100 free the link to join is in the
description below
you really have to believe the
internet's going to be mainstream
before we were able to get the roadster
out then they'd say
well you couldn't possibly make that car
work if everything has to work in two to
three years
then that limits what you can do lesson
number four
get some haters with grant cardone you
got to get some haters
you need haters no school is going to
teach you how to get a hater
okay high school elementary school
colleges what do they teach
you want to be the most popular person
no you want haters
okay the companies that are hated are
the companies that are exploding
the people that are hated are the people
that explode
if i don't hate you if nobody hates you
nobody knows you
so the reason i'll tweet for instance
when we started we had this
uh that newsletter that i sent out okay
we sent it out every week
we were hitting people once a month and
we started getting complaints
you send stuff out too much my office
came to me
we went to twice a month they came to me
we have
more people pulling off of the
newsletter good
double up again why i want haters
okay so we started sending out one every
week and then i started twitter account
i actually had people write grant
cardone social media people grant
cardone
is an example of what not to do with
social media
i said freaking just multiply
just increase it okay we were doing like
four tweets a day good due to an hour
why because i want my competition hating
my guts i want them talking about me i
mean i don't really want hate people to
hate me you understand what i'm saying
about
i want them so so energized that they
actually start
pushing me they start promoting me
lesson number five be disruptive with
jesse itzler
what happened after uh the music success
you know you're reinvesting
and you sold the company did you stay in
the music world did you
so we branch out well we sold the
company to a public company
and the owner of this po of the public
company guy named bob silliman at sfx
had a private jet and invited my partner
and i
on a trip we were the youngest uh
company that he bought as far as
we were 25 or 26 years old we sold the
company
and he took a liking to us kind of like
young guys
invited us on a trip and went on a
private jet and um
as soon as we got on the plane we kind
of looked at each other and like
how in the world do we do this more
often like wow how do we get this
right and um ultimately that one
trip led to a private jet business that
we started called marquee jet so you
just decided that you're going to launch
a jet company
well we had this we had the idea because
we wanted to use it right so like you
know what even if no one else signs up
for this thing and we can fly on a
private jet
that would be a win but uh it was a
completely different
uh skill set and business and industry
that you
didn't have any experience and i'm
assuming right i mean that's kind of a
theme for me
i mean i think one of the things that i
look back on my life and i was in music
i was in private jets i've been in
coconut water and all these different
things
sports um is that i had no prior
experience in
any of that and it ended up being the
best blessing for me because
no one taught me or told me how to do it
so it was guaranteed that it would be
done differently
interesting and that was uh you know it
guaranteed it would be creative and
different and unique
so no neither my partner and i or i had
any background and i mean we couldn't
even make a
paper airplane right now and we didn't
have
to buy a plane so you weren't a pilot
either on the zoo no
no okay but we had an idea you had a
passion for it we had an idea
um and intuitively i think we both knew
it would work because we knew if we
wanted to use
this product that probably a lot of
people would want to use it and how can
we make it
more affordable and bring it to the
masses so what did you do tell me the
problem then what the solution was
well the problem was there was only
three ways to fly privately at the time
you could buy your own airplane which is
incredibly expensive
it takes out 99.9 percent of the world
you could
buy a fraction of a plane which is like
a time share which is also
very expensive and it's a long
commitment and that's not what we don't
want to put a couple of million dollars
in for multiple years we wanted to take
like three trips a year with our friends
to golf
yeah or you could charter a plane and
there's all kinds of questions about
like well who owns the plane who's
flying the plane what if the plane
doesn't show up you know inconsistencies
so
we were like if we could just offer a
25-hour solution
with none of the responsibilities of
owning your own plane you have to manage
it you have to schedule it you just like
call on demand it shows up and you
pre-pay for it
and just work off the hours it will work
it's like the uber for planes
yeah but there was one problem what we
didn't have any planes
okay so we we once we had the idea
and we had it all kind of baked we had
to go find out find someone that could
lend us
a fleet of airplanes right how many did
you want to start with uh
well we sat next to each other like you
and i are doing it
uh my partner asked me how many people
you think would buy this that you know
and i said i could probably sell 15. he
said all right put me down for 15 and
said we need
enough to hold 30 people wow and um
we went to netjets which is owned by
warren buffett
and uh and berkshire and with this idea
are they based out of columbus
yeah whenever i fly in i see big netjets
on
and um had this meeting to pitch this
idea that was gonna change my life
and they throw us out in about 10
minutes why uh
i think the direct quote is sounds cool
if you guys think i'm giving two 27 year
olds my fleet of airplanes
it's not happening you're out of your
mind yeah and um
but his partner came out after the
meeting and said that was a great
meeting
i said what are you talking about we got
thrown out in 12 12 minutes
he said rich santouli the ceo doesn't
give anyone 12 minutes
and so if you guys kind of just do this
change this do this
come back let's try it again so we did
but instead of coming back with the deck
we brought in our own focus group we
literally just lined up like eight
chairs
of athletes entertainers agents people
afford it
right and one by one they stood up and
explained why they wouldn't buy their
own plane why they wouldn't buy a net
jet fraud
and why they would buy this cart wow and
we got a deal
and then a year later you know we were i
think we had more customers than that
yet
lesson number six keep experimenting
with larry ellison
throughout my 20s i continued
experimenting
trying different things racing bikes and
boats and constantly changing jobs
it didn't take me long to discover that
the most interesting and rewarding
programming jobs
were found at a cluster of companies
located south of stanford university in
north of san jose
silicon valley was in its infancy
i was still in my 20s when i went to
work for my first silicon valley startup
amdahl where we developed the world's
fastest mainframe computer
faster than anything ibm had next stop
was ampex
where we built the world's largest
digital data storage system
then on to precision instruments where
we built an even larger data storage
system
this time using lasers i was the vice
president and charged with software
development
it was all very cutting edge and
challenging and cool
i like my work most of the time but i
didn't love it
i searched and i searched but i just
could not find a software engineering
job
that i loved as much as i loved sailing
so i tried to create one i put together
a plan to start my own company
that way i could completely control my
work environment
i would hire the most talented
programmers i knew
and we would all work together on the
most
interesting and challenging software
projects
my group my goal was to create the
perfect job
for me a job i truly loved i never ex
i never expected the company to grow
beyond 50 people
and lesson number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is play it smart with mark cuban when
instead of just holding on to all of the
stock that you got from yahoo
you did what we call a collar you
colored it
so you hedged it so tell everybody what
went through your mind because that was
a
big bet with huge dollars right and it
was a pr
it was actually pretty simple so you
know hedging stock if
you know yahoo paid us in yahoo stock
and you know i was smart enough to
recognize i guess
that what goes up could go down but it
wasn't that big a step because
i was worth more than a billion dollars
how much did i need right
so i was telling everybody just find me
a way to hedge it
so in the event look if the stock price
goes up and i leave something on the
table
so be it right but i like that being
next to my name and i wanted to keep it
and so
i sold calls bought puts and effectively
hedged it so that
by the time so there was a period of
time from when i'd done that
and the internet stock market kept on
going up and and i told people i'd
hedged it and goldman sachs the company
had
told people what i'd done and i remember
going on cnbc the business channel
and then the guy going boy don't you
feel stupid that yahoo stock has kept on
going up and you had this hedge
and i'm like yeah i feel so stupid
riding around my g5 that i bought online
you know and and it was just like not to
sound like a crazy greasy greedy
capitalist but
yeah and it was like i just didn't want
to screw it up
and so i hedged it and then the internet
bubble burst
and i was fully protected and actually
even made a little bit more money
and you know middle um you know the
motto that
what i learned was you just you don't
need to be greedy
you know i was very very blessed i was
very fortunate
look i didn't plan the internet stock
market to go up and i didn't plan to go
down so i was lucky in terms of scale
and i didn't want to screw it up and so
i hedged
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an
action plan for what you're going to do
you increase it from 35
to 91 chance of you actually following
through and
when you share your plan publicly that
jumps to
95 chance of following through so i want
that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you if you could go back and talk to
your
younger self go build the time machine
and go back and talk to your younger
self
what what advice would you give the
younger you that maybe you didn't
realize about yourself
that you wish you did when you were
younger well the first thing that pops
into my mind is that he shows up
he shows up he shows up and i think he's
sitting in the audience here
but i spent a lot of time as a younger
self worrying about
am i going to meet the right one am i
going to be able to have children am i
going to start a family and i would tell
my younger self just chill out he shows
up
just do your thing don't spend any
mental energy on that but it's hard you
know especially as a woman
i really wanted to be financially
independent i wanted to chart my own way
but i also
was really wanting to to be a mother and
have another side of my life so
that's what i would say very good he
shows up he took his time i didn't get
married till i was 37
38 but now we have four children
[Music]
if you want seven more awesome lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there you must find a
way
to serve
martin luther king said that not
everybody can be famous but everybody
can be great